it's fun to be in a cross-disciplinary
group so basically I mostly talk to
economists and sociologists and then to
talk to people that often our subjects
in our studies is actually really really
fun um Stanford this is a person that
Stanford is near and dear to my heart my
mother in the 70s left Pakistan to come
to Stanford to do a master's degree and
that enabled us to emigrate in the early
80s to to Canada and it was really the
Stanford education that really set us up
for the for where we are today as a
family and it's always had a soft spot
in our in our hearts and of course when
I was considering graduate school was
transferred was at the top of my list
and somehow MIT kept winning over every
single time but I'm super happy to be
here and to present this work this work
is in collaboration with Kevin Boudreau
my good friend and co-author at the
London Business School we went to MIT
together as PhD students and have
started to work together on a bunch of
these kinds of questions and so what I'm
going to talk about you saw the title I
keep changing the title around to make
it more simpler this is the new title
you know how disclosure policies impact
search and open innovation I'm gonna
explain to you all this as we move
forward I just want to give you a sense
of my research and how it all fits in
I've been really been thinking a lot
about you know how crowds get organized
and how we can get productive work from
crowds and there's really two major
institutions that we see out an economy
that enabled us to work with crowds the
first setup is competitions and contests
and in this in this work I've done a
bunch of work to sort of explain who
wins and why you know what are the basis
for for performance in these settings
why people participate and behavior in
contests and I've done both research
using archival data looking at
InnoCentive and topcoder
to pull out these results and also a
field experiments and we'll walk you
through a field experiment soon the
other way to set this up is actually
through a community so everybody's aware
of the open-source software world and
what that's done and I've if I started
my research first there to say you know
how does open-source work and why does
that actually
produced such robust quality software
and again I've looked at issues about
motivation self selection and
participation and and now doing
increasingly more work around partner a
selection and clap for collaboration
through field experiments as well and in
many ways these two institutions are
diametrically opposed if you sort of
think about it in the one case you're
basically running a winner-take-all
contest where people are competing and
trying to rushing to solve a problem and
the other setting you have communities
people are sharing knowledge you know
they're learning from each other and the
collectively improving the the the
overall perspective of the code being
produced and or performance of the code
being produced and for me this has
always been a puzzle in terms of what's
the better way to organize ourselves
should be when we have a creative task
when you have us offer programming tasks
and we have a scientific task is it
better for us to set up ourselves in
communities and collaborations or is it
better for us to set up contests and
competitions in many ways I started here
this I was actually kind of allergic to
when I first started paying attention to
this during my dissertation time because
I just I didn't you know drank the
open-source kool-aid and I just felt
like that was just a great way to
organize work but as these became more
and more popular and powerful it
required attention to say like what's
going on here and why are these equally
as effective as this and that's what the
puzzle I'm gonna try to solve or the
next time that time we have the work I
do is part of what's called the NASA
tournament lab it's a it's a research
lab funded by NASA to help us understand
how these types of open innovation
perspectives can be put to use for
government agencies but for innovation
in general and so what we do is we work
with NASA we take their toughest
computational challenges and then we
crowdsource them through platforms like
top coder I've also done a bunch of work
with our medical school in the
computational biology side of things or
again saying that in fact we can take
computation biology questions and also
get them solved through contests and
communities and in addition a bunch of
work pieces hang on a second
and a bunch of work around how we
actually organize collaborations in the
medical school setting so if you look at
the Harvard Medical School you know we
have 20,000 researchers about 1.5
billion dollars in funding from the NIH
and you know for three campuses that are
far apart from each other how we find
collaborators and partners is actually a
big big question here and that's part of
our research agenda that we also pursue
so let me give you an example first of a
contest we recently ran for NASA for the
space station so let's have a look
energy in one form or another powers
everything on earth and the man-made
things floating above it - this is the
International Space Station you've
probably heard of it it's powered by the
Sun and the sun's energy is captured by
the station solar panels ensuring the
space station harvests the most energy
possible is a complicated as well for
one reason see those large solar panels
holding them to the station are very
long thin arms called launderers any
time an odd number of lingeries are in
full sunlight with others in the shadows
cast by the rest of the space station
they bent and eventually brittle for
this reason ISS operators are careful to
position the station to limit shadowing
and so only an even number of launcher
ons are shadowed at one time however
this conservative positioning reduces
the power the station can collect from
the Sun thus causing inefficiency NASA
wants more power for the ISS more power
means more science and cool style that
NASA can do on orbit NASA needs a
sophisticated algorithm and they think
you just might be the key to this whole
equation introducing the NASA tournament
Labs International Space Station
lingerie challenge your solutions just
may help power the International Space
Station and allow more science from more
scientists around the world consider
this your invitation to blast off with
NASA
for more information visit TopCoder
dot-com / ISS if you've got the right
stuff so this ran in March you know 30 K
pool of cash available to solve this
problem was a three week long
contest here's what we got we had broad
engagement you know foreign and 59
competitors submitting about about two
thousand code submissions we had
actually had two thousand signups I was
quite incredible NASA can be a big draw
for people to participate the winners I
hear so Italian Chinese Chinese polish
Chinese Estonian Chinese Canadian
Chinese and Belarusian yes exactly what
are you guys doing about it and so this
you know so we get we get broad
engagement and really cool cloak code of
course NASA cares about like how good is
the code right does it actually do
anything at all and what we have here
for you is the final output of the code
submissions that they had for how much
power up but you can get based on the
configurations that they predicted and
this is sort of you know solar power
output and then this is every single
person that had submitted and their
final submissions now some things you'll
see immediately said there's actually
quite a bit of bunching right if people
have done really well and in many ways
so that the the differences between the
first and second are not that great but
then here is a NASA solution
okay and depending upon how you model
the NASA solution which is our solutions
you know we rather exceed or meet what
they've done alright so in what was you
know multi your you know multi xtal
millions of dollars or projects that
they do to get this kind of information
out we were able to basically get done
in three weeks for 30 K and this becomes
a very compelling way for us to think
about organizing creative work if we can
actually take these very tough software
problems that require lots of people and
lots of attention and say can we
actually get it done this way so it so
in fact that's a good question up
surprise sizes in fact a still art than
a science what we're finding is that too
high a prize and that'll actually deter
entry because people think the problem
is too hard and but you want to actually
reward people for for their efforts as
well so we've been typically in these
types of projects in the 10 to 50 K
depending upon the problem and and what
we're trying to get done on the on the
backend side yes that's on the high end
for top coat or top coat of projects are
typically much smaller than that they'll
be like $500 or $1,500 but those are for
more software components these are
longer-term projects three weeks four
weeks and so on and of course as we'll
discuss later
you know there's beyond just surprise
money here you know having get your code
assessed by NASA or having your name on
the wall and you know in terms of the
competitors is actually as important as
as a probably surprise about as well the
other component actually is the time
like how long should we run the
competition for I always felt that we
should be running like we had a big
debate should this be a three week
contest or a six week contest and what
we're finding again this is more
anecdotal is that we you know there's a
deadline effect so people you know will
well like everybody here you know works
to the deadline so right you know the
night before there's a ton of stuff
going on but but there's also sort of
diminishing returns
having it run for long pursuit I'm so so
so we're actually running shorter
contests you know with you know 10k 15k
20k 30k prize amounts just to get the
ball rolling and attract lots of people
participating yes this one was you
you're competing on your own people
could see a leaderboard that was show
where you were in terms of performance
but the code was secret the experiment
I'll talk to you about we had both of
those kinds of treatments in there yes
yes so I think that's an open question
for us you know there's a company called
Local Motors which is building cars
through crowds it's a car design and so
on is being so the design that you saw
the space station they're actually
sourcing from cars from the crowd as
well so i think i think we're for sure
when it comes to information products we
have seen crowds perform amazingly well
from wikipedia to open source to this
kind of stuff what's happening was
interesting is that the whole world is
going digital the whole world is
becoming an information product right
any physical object can be represented
as you know with this information shadow
and then we can then put on the computer
and let all you guys go crazy at it this
is actually what's so interesting that
in fact as we as the entire world gets
digital and cyberspace is actual real
space then these approaches are becoming
more and more effective I think in this
one--this we had those 10 winners but
again sometimes it's 2 or 5 depending
upon what we were blue Britannic I
encourage here because certain people
don't participate because there are only
2 or 5 winners so if I'm an OK
programmer I'd probably be we left them
to play a game where I'm probably not
going to
absolutely genetic there's a whole skill
effect there's a whole della and a fact
and then once you see other people doing
really well you're like oh I should
maybe stop you know it's all those
elements come into it absolutely the
best coder is kind of come into the
system and try to get better yeah
there's some work we're doing now and
saying what happens if we actually
limited the transparency of the signal
being generated because right now this
is a public signal right everybody sees
your performance everybody sees how good
you are right what happens if you get
you limited that signals Oh only you had
it and then you could then keep and you
had the option to turn that on or off
and that that may in fact have a have
some very interesting consequences
absolutely right so let me move on and
walk you through the paper in a quick
nutshell then we'll get into all the
gory details so I'm going to take a very
broad view and we think about innovation
systems you know we think about the
patent system academic science we think
of open source these are all what
society has invented over time and these
all systems designed to both encourage
innovation we want innovation to happen
so we create incentives but we also want
disclosure we actually want those
inventions to be made available for the
people to use in fact in our
Constitution right the patent system is
part of the of the Constitution because
they the the the the founders felt like
we needed to create incentives for
inventors but also disclose those
inventions so these two components are
part and parcel of how we think about
innovation and what we ascertain and
we'll talk about is that what makes them
different is really the timing of
disclosure so all innovation systems are
in fact open so even if you think about
patents right patents are open because
you have to publicly disclose your
invention and how it got done you just
have monopoly rights over what happens
through its use later on right similarly
in science open science right you
publish a paper right that's what gets
disclosed and that's what gives you
accolades and so the timing is what what
what makes these things different
instead of just sort of this battles
about open versus closed um and what we
show in this paper is that assists
like open-source where there's lots of
intermediate disclosures where sharing
code snippets we're sharing intermediate
advances with each other actually
dampens incentives and participation so
we get color to what I expected
get lower participation lower effort in
these systems yet we get higher
performance and we'll try to explain why
that is going on and we see in fact see
more experimentation right and more
exploration in closed systems and we'll
explain why that may be going on and and
the argument that we make is that
there's a real convergence of technical
paths that people follow in open systems
in intermediate disclosure systems that
enables them to get high performance but
this has implications for how we think
about the knowledge stocks that are
available to people and who's
participating in the in these systems
along the way because in innovation what
happens is that in the end there are
some out sized returns to what what's
going on absolutely so so what all
Expedia is is our best attempt to not
talk about open source for said open
science but to say what's what
differentiates open source from open
science per se or from closed it open is
the is the regime of intermediate
disclosure as one one element right that
sort of says we can share what we will
be done right away with everybody else
and and and other people can build on
that so we use that as our sort of our
treatment to say does that how does that
in fact happen to work out in a system
where people are able to use anybody
else's code and still retain some kind
of rewards at the end it's continually
being built upon people are disclosing
different things oh it's not an
innovation task per se you know they're
just creating content but that would be
in the same line
absolutely okay so so let's just talk
about these dual objectives for
innovation systems so the first is you
want to offer incentives for inventive
effort right so patents allow monopoly
rights or use rights academia is based
on funding promotion
awards and honor and open sources use
benefits as reputation and trinsic
rewards and so on they come into it all
these elements are basically ways for
society to sort of say we want to reward
inventive effort at the same time right
we want to ensure that inventions like
the Google glass get disclosed right
that in fact people know how these
things work and that other people can
build upon that and that's the that's
the that's the essential trade-off that
the society makes we want incentives for
invention but we also want disclosure so
you know patent is of course you make
knowledge in public domain and academia
you're publishing or perishing you got
to publish right if you don't publish
you don't you don't exist as an academia
you want to disclose what you've
discovered and an open source is sort of
enshrined in the process people are
always making disclosures and it can
also be in the license itself so these
are the dual goals of of all systems and
there's a we think is a false debate
between sort of closed and open
innovation it's really all innovation
systems are geared to be open in the end
right it's just a matter of when you
enforce disclosures and what timing it
is and what form they take but
everything that society does beyond I
think trade secrets is geared towards
openness so we can get into a lot of
sort of semantic battles but open which
is closed innovation and what works
better but really the difference we
argue is one about disclosure and when
disclosure is happening so one format is
sort this final disclosure right so if
you think about patents a completed
invention is put out there right for
other people to consume later on in
academia it's a published paper right we
submit a paper we do the experiment we
do the work and you publish a paper and
in prize contests some technologies
develop that becomes available for other
people to use so we call that sort of
final disclosure which later allows
people to them build upon and so forth
but the process is a secret and not a
bill for the people to participate
within in the world of an immediate
disclosure we actually have the setting
where where we're constantly making
available our advances to everybody else
and a great example actually was the
human genome project the human genome
project in the 90s basically once they
once they were under attack from Solara
actually in the race to sequence the
human genome they actually came up with
this radical approach called the Bermuda
principles there were in Bermuda for a
conference you know great place and they
said any discovery that's made by any
lab as their sequencing human genome
will be made immediately available to
everybody else publicly disclosed all
right this violates the most principles
of academic science because we we keep
our data secret we keep our experiments
secret and we have a race for priority
to publish our papers and here they said
no in fact we're gonna make everything
available very quickly so people could
then actually coordinate their
activities and go after things that
haven't been done before of course an
open source and the world that we live
in you know there's code fragments
advice and tips on problems all been
completely code everything is being
continuously being disclosed and you
know for me it's shocking to some some
of the students here before you know
having been at the start of the open
source movement when this when this
stuff was taking hold so our experience
now of going to Stack Exchange and
asking somebody for help and reading
their solutions was not the the default
right before people didn't have those
hints available you might have Usenet
available if you guys know what using
that is as a solution but that was all
comment so all these things are in fact
new in terms of behavior change in
society in terms of us being able to
live with this and certainly in the
world of biology there's biological
repositories you can actually get
microorganisms and mice
you know mice have code and them and the
that people can share and use for their
own experiments as well but here we're
actually again making intermediate
products available for people to reuse
and you know what's interesting is that
this is also a historically important
process so lots of studies now in the
history of technology is showing that
you know the airplane Bessemer steel you
know blast furnace technology all those
were based upon systems of collective
invention or lots of people were sharing
knowledge throughout and teams of
engineers
teams allow distributed teams of people
were sharing knowledge back and forth to
make this happen and in fact some work
by Meyer in fact shows that all the the
u.s. system was actually very open and
open to sharing lots of knowledge flows
having in the US and once the Wright
brothers came up with their invention
there were parts of the little
participants in the system once they
came up they mentioned they actually
started to patent and and the the the
the the the locus of activity for
aircraft and mission then moved over to
France where there were no patents on
aircraft at that time so if you think
about words like early on or fuselage
was all French words because that's
where all those developments were being
done and and in the u.s. actually had
actually a dip in in in an invented
output for aircraft for a while but but
but this is the world that exists and so
we have within this set up this
incentives versus reuse trade-off within
our our invention systems and the key
concern we have is balancing exon2
incentives can I encourage you to exert
effort and spend time and money working
on a problem right at the same time come
up with a system that says that the
disclosures that you that the inventions
you come up with will be available to
everybody else and the the worry is and
in the economics literature is that as
you bringing greater disclosures right
you will do great incentives people will
not will not invest effort because they
won't be able to appropriate those
rewards for later on alright this is
classical economics 101 in terms of as
as my use rights decline I'm going to be
less inclined to work and what's
happened in our society is that we
create compensating mechanisms for
greater disclosure so we have things
like priority and citations in academia
that are worth something that we can use
and signing an authorship in an open
source which says that there will be
other rewards for participation other
than direct use rights or monopoly
rights that could be useful as well
and
also we may actually attract different
people with different ethos for sharing
and so forth as well and so that's not a
society sort of dealt with this with
this perspective um but the centre's
matter a lot so we're in the gates
building so I thought I'd use a quote
from Bill Gates so you know in 1976
right he writes basically a letter to
hackers right saying incentives matter I
said it's matter a lot and he built
Microsoft right on this company on the
spaces that that proprietary incentives
matter a lot and you know were the
benefactors of that of that of this
letter and what he was able to do in
terms of innovation but there's also the
Torvalds perspective right so then a
store wallace comes back out of the 90s
right and he says hey you know do you
pine for the days when men were men
those are all men at that time and we're
doing device drivers right are you
without a nice project deciding to cut
your teeth on an OS you can try to
modify for your needs I'm doing a free
operating system just a hobby it won't
be a big and professional like feedback
on things this is a program for hackers
parkour enjoy doing it somebody might
enjoy looking at it drop me a line if
they're willing to let me use your code
right so he's definitely on the you know
compensating mechanisms for incentives
and about sharing and reuse and we are
living now in this world of both of
these institutions at least in the world
of software existing coexisting and
people going back and forth oftentimes
between them all right so this debate is
not just theoretical this is real people
make choices make investments based on
where they end up on this on this debate
what we know from research and economics
is that more open more access equals to
increase reuse so the whole whole world
of user innovation have shown that that
that people once you've make technology
available people will reuse them and
share them and keep keep using them over
and over again
of course platform encourage you reuse
of components you disclose those
components and then platforms grow and
become really powerful because we've got
those components available and academic
science has shown that basically future
citation rates are a function of reuse
rights the more we use rights you
provide to people the higher
we use become so it's a very obvious
kind of a finding that you would sort of
expect um but what's missing is the
counterfactual what we don't know is
what happens when both the systems are
in play and how do people aren't you at
work out so the perspective I'm going to
bring is that while we have a view about
innovation in terms of incentives and
reuse we also have to think about
innovation as a search process you're
searching for the best solution and it's
not just a production function thing
where we think about incentives and
outputs and efforts but we actually want
to think about this as a search process
and there's a there's a broad literature
in economics in management that thinks
about innovation as a search process and
if you think about the search process
what what you want to think about is
your there's some kind of a landscape on
which you're searching for the best
solution and that landscape may have
peaks and valleys and you want to find
the highest peak along the way yes we're
actually the very non through the next
election where you just jump over to
something that no one even considered
was actually going to be useful yes so
question is do be invent the solution
landscapes as we do the problem-solving
or do they already exist but I think I
think that's that's that's a I don't
think the the literature has looked at
sort of invention sort of endogenous
invention of of solution landscapes I
think I think it happens for sure but I
don't think we have an apparatus yet and
the innovation literature to actually
deal with that and to think about how
about how that may come through you know
we could have made a dumb mobile phone
that has longer battery but in fact we
ended up with this very different
problem which was designing a that's
right you know a handheld computer
that's right that's right
yeah if you start with problem saying I
need more energy efficiency or something
you never would have found that
you know and I think you know in my
other work on contest we actually think
that defining the problem is actually a
big part of what makes it was drive
success and so then there's some effort
and saying we actually need problem
designers right now problem solvers
right because if if crowds can solve any
problem right then we need actually
really good problems to give them and
that that's a whole different skill and
I think the D schools are the ones that
are probably pushing the boundaries on
that I don't think you know management
schools are anywhere near near that
perspective absolutely companies often
fuel if they want to be open to
innovation but it's hard to actually
make that that change yeah absolutely I
think I think that's that that's a core
core element that I think needs to be
worked on how difficult is it to share
work in progress because I think that
that's also another deterrent right
there a there are few incentives and B
it's just hard to give your work way out
there and let others use it yeah so I'm
going to show you a Felix I remember we
made it super easy but the
practicalities that is actually really
there are transactions cost and sharing
all right we have tools available now
for us to share more easily and more
broadly but it still is effort so I'm
gonna try to take care of that to these
premises but you know that's that's what
that's what experiments allowing us to
do all right so and so the the element
so think about when we think about
innovation a search is that the
direction and path where research
activity is as important as is as
important consideration right so this is
exactly the point you made which is like
you know which direction are we going to
go after are we going to go after sort
of a low end cellphone that lasts for 30
days right or one that has nine hours of
life and then you're like scrambling to
find the power those are choices that
people make and those choices can either
be correlated or they can be independent
and that's the point we're going to try
to address here going forward and you
know there's again a big literature
about innovation happening along
pathways trajectories and and paradigms
and the the thing to keep in mind is
that as we think about disclosure right
we may in fact get either parallel
independent paths or we may get
conversion paths and this is the big
thing that we're going to try to unpack
in our in our work so there's been a
whole bunch of formal mathematical
models of search based on Simon's work
and Kaufman's and Kei models and what we
have shown the literature shown is that
in fact you know multiple independent
search trajectories parallel search is
important to find high-value solutions
to problems at the same time we know
from this literature that communities of
innovators tend to converge on paths all
right so we need to be able to do to be
able to ascertain between them and we
want to think about concerns about local
versus global Optima all right so what
do we do I'm gonna I've got a bunch of
predictions they're kind of wordy I just
want to show you what what we thought
about in the paper and then we'll get in
the data the first petition we made is
that in fact in a in a in a in a regime
where you have enemies disclosure will
actually see incentives drop people will
not work as hard will not participate as
much as compared to the regime where
there's no intermediate disclosure we
our second prediction from the
literature is that in fact we see you
know much more experimentation and
closed regimes that in open regimes and
in and the third prediction is that in
the open regimes we see a lot of
convergence and and the convergence and
the performance will depend upon the
stock of knowledge that already exists
all right and so we'll try to show how
these all three elements work for them
for you okay so what we did is we
implement a field experiment it's
actually tough for us to to do this in
the natural world because it's hard for
us to compare open source to open
science they're both open and and in
wording but very different sets of
people were a different sets of outputs
it's hard to compare across them so
going to a field experiment setting is
better because then we can control a
bunch of things on the way and what we
try to see is what happens when we bring
about about a treatment of other
intermediate
disclosure versus final disclosure okay
and see the cause of effect of those
things we use the topcoder online
platform we offered like six thousand
bucks and two weeks and we took a
problem from Harvard Medical School a
sort of a genomics problem to solve this
to make this challenge happen and what
we can do is we can distinguish between
technical approaches and we have lots of
Micro data on entry effort their ability
to peek on other people's solutions and
individual level data but who these
people are so what's the problem so
basically you know in genomics one big
issue is sequence alignment you get lots
of reads of sequences and then you wanna
be able to assemble them together big
problem and what we're trying to see is
can we actually apply this to a really
huge problem in immunology where they're
trying to do the whole work of the
magenta mix where the data constraints
are the data explosion is really huge
and the challenge with basically a can
you annotate a hundred thousand
sequences on a laptop right initially
details about the contest so what are we
set up we had in the we analysis on top
coder and we have 733 people sign up say
this looks like an interesting challenge
for me to work on I'm gonna participate
and what we do then is we we have great
data on skills I'll show you in a minute
but the skills data we have because
skills are actually a really important
control you want to have in any kind of
analysis of crowdsourcing because it
could just be that we're trying to in
the really top skill guys and that
explains the performance dimensions
right away so we worked really hard to
make sure that we can act in fact
control for skills and all of our
analyses right so we took these
individuals right you rank order them by
skill and then we took triplets of
closely tied folks and assign them
randomly to you know an intermediate
disclosure regime a mixed regime and
upon disclosure regime which I'll
explain to you all right and so
basically we had about two and forty
four two and forty five people assigned
to these regimes and then we had prize
amounts here as well for getting the
problem solved in week one and week two
and the intermediate disclosure regime
what happened was you would you got the
problem statement and basic
in order for you to know how good your
solution is you had to submit the
solution back to the system and as soon
as you submitted that solution about the
system it made that code available to
everybody else to use okay so you got a
score but then your code anybody else
can look at and basically reuse as they
wanted to leave both in a citation
system to allow for sharing of rewards
but we actually basically had that setup
in in the in the in the final disclosure
regime basically nothing happened
everything was dark
right you submitted your code you got a
score people saw your score and that's
it and then you could keep moving on and
then we set up a mixed regime as a
control to allow us to do one week of
clothes and one week of open to allow us
to see for robustus testing was it also
tied to my yes you saw code you saw
identity absolutely yeah all put
together and then again you know so this
prize pool first place price of 500
bucks 250 125 and so on all right
and the this the disclosure regime was
really one of click so we just made it
super easy right you just click on the
thing you got the entire code base and
you could then see its evolution over
time all right and then we and what we
do is you know we whole cost in the
problem the assignments interface the
production technology at the time the
market signal the top total purse and
the top five prizes in the in the
disclosure regime they could and the
intermediates or they could they could
they could chat and the other regime
they couldn't yeah we have be happy I
don't use that in my analysis but we
have that available to us as well is
there anything I'm just rising existing
no you could take it all and the light
get late you you could if you if you
kept doing it and you could get the top
prize if you monitor okay this is just
like open source right you could take
something you code or go to github press
copy and paste and be up and running
yeah so so you can imagine right what's
going on this is exactly the underlying
question we have like if you implement a
disclosure regime like this where it's
available right away to everybody else
what are the inside
okay so just in terms of the overall
performance of the system it actually
rocked quite good so let me just show
you so again so we had 733 signups 122
people ask you submit a code we
uncovered 89 different approaches to
solve the problem okay so not only do we
got high numbers but we get diversity
which is actually really important for
innovation winners from Russia France
Egypt Belgium and us right people that
you know the medical school who didn't
know existed and could never even hire
right for many reasons and you know
basically we go down to being able to
sequence you know quarter-billion
sequences in one hour on a laptop right
so pretty awesome results but let me
show you the results graphically so our
our our scoring function of two two
elements one was time how fast were you
able to do this and the second was
accuracy
alright point eight is the theoretical
accurate the threat of maximum accuracy
could get from this data set all right
these are all the submissions that we
got from our from our folks the green
the green dots and this is a log scale
all right so you know B want to be here
basically this is the NIH mega blast
solution and this is the code from the
Harvard researcher who volunteered to
give us their problem so you know he's
no slouch it's a good colleague of mine
you know undergrad from MIT PhD from
Oxford you know is in at Beth Israel as
a pathologist and a computational
biologist and has a lab working on this
problem right and oh by the way none of
these guys have any background in
computational biology right because what
we did is we took the problem from from
biology and made it into a math problem
looking through science problem then
these guys would go at it yeah how are
you identifying the differences like
was manual grunt work but there was
somebody else not okay so who signed up
so again we had all these people seven
thirty people to show up from 69
different countries okay forty four
percent of them were professionals and
55 percent were students are their PhD
or masters undergraduate programs so a
lot of these guys here maybe show up
what is that exactly
and then you know sort of they on the
younger side of the population
distribution but that's not a surprise
right by the time you're busy and then
also a big distribution of skills
all right so TopCoder has a an elo based
skills rating which looks at every
person and looks at the history of
competition and based on that gives them
a metric of skill I think I might even
have it Yeah right here so we can see
here this guy he's from Brazil his he's
a red rated coder and you can see his
performance in algorithmic matches over
time and he's here so sort of really on
the on the high end of the distribution
in terms of performance so this this
this is generated IDO is a way that a
chess grandmasters get evaluated against
each other and they've implanted the
same system for for programmers so we
have a good sense of the skills of the
individuals participating with us okay
so what what did we see first I'm just
going to show you some pictures to sort
of drive home the point there's no fancy
econometrics here at all all right so
one is lower participation over all
right in the intermediate disclosure
regime right so you can see both in
terms of number of active entrants and
the cumulative number of entrants you
know who shows up right and there's a
and I'll show you some more results in a
second I'd show you some p-values but
just from this you can start to see you
know that incentives matter like your
question and as soon as you're in a
regime where for the same sets of people
where you change when you when you bring
in more disclosure you will have actual
F century and again this was contrary to
my bias my advice was that open more
participation but in fact we're seeing
the incentive story kick in here
the second thing is ours worked as well
and this is by skill you know big
difference pretty much across the
distribution in terms of of people
working on their problems
alright so few people enter they exert
less effort and overall what we find is
you know participation rates are about
26% lower in an intermediate number of
submissions are 56% lower right and
hours work are about 30% lower okay
overall so people are putting in time
but still it's quite it's quite quite
quite quite important to sort of see at
these these regimes so when we see open
source and this great mobilization open
source the SKA be other things going on
beyond just the real incentive effect of
participation
yes so what we see is that what what
what happens is that one could make the
argument from our data that open is more
socially efficient right in two ways why
don't you allow for reuse right and
secondly you actually because we have
this drop out right people are like are
being allocated in the economy better
right because I see you participating oh
he's a hotshot I'm not even gonna show
up because there's no way I'm ever going
to be able to you know to improve upon
which you've done so that may also be
going on as well okay
all right and then also the problem
solving performance was higher in
intermediate because of this reduce
effect which I'll show you then then in
the final and average score was 1.6
points higher controlling for skill and
effort so we basically have a whole lot
of controls here in the regression that
allows us to basically show and one
point six actually makes a difference
between being top or not overall so this
is this is quite quite quite interesting
for us to see as well all right so you
see a story coming together about what's
happening in in a world of disclosure
and the question you have when you're in
a world of being able to look at other
people's code people are peeking a lot
people are
looking at code and learning from it and
in fact doing it so we have about about
I believe close to a thousand thousand
incidences the people looking at because
we could see when they clicked on the
other code here and then in the mixed
regime
you know it's flat of course in the
first week in a second week it again
takes off most of the peaking occurred
in the first week where people were
looking at the code bases and trying to
send with the best pass war okay so what
explains these results how do we
actually make sense of these results so
the first thing we want to understand is
how do we actually discern the solution
paths right how do we actually figure
this out so what we had was we got a top
coder participant poor reuleaux to in
fact look through the code bases and see
what were the elemental techniques being
used by the programmers themselves so he
made an inventory of basically sampling
a whole bunch of submissions across the
distribution and saying what's being
used and he came up with all these
different approaches so that basically
ten distinct elemental approaches being
used and then we had other top coder
PhDs you know one German and two Chinese
to go through every submission right and
say you know are they using this or not
along the way okay and then what we do
is we do solutions are a combination of
techniques right so it's basically a bit
bit switch one zero one one one of the
ten different ways to do that and you
can then look at how to unique are those
are those approaches being put together
so it's a manual effort we weren't smart
enough to sort of how somehow
computerized his effort but it got us a
really high level of fidelity to do this
so basically you sort of see you know
you see here this was our sequence
alignment project this is the coder this
is a submission and you can see his code
and then you can see what's what's going
on in this code all right so paths are
consequential all right so what I'm
showing you are two graphics this is
performance versus combination of
approaches and we're just basically
rank-ordered them right by average score
within the approach right and the number
of people that did this and we've
transformed the score here as well so
what you see is that you know
you know some pads you know have you
know have a really low score effects and
some pads have really high okay and the
second thing we see is that the number
of Elemental techniques you use to solve
the problem are in fact consequential as
well so the more techniques you use the
higher the average score okay so both
things matter and what's interesting as
a counterfactual for us is that when we
look at what mega blasts had done or
what you know the harbour boosts which
are done we were really like orders
advantage more than with what they had
done in terms of the approaches they had
considered and here we see the entire
landscape basically coming through the
second thing I just want you to sort of
look at this sort of this picture say
the search patterns are very different
right
so in though in the world of knowing
disclosures you basically have this
gyration going on people are going up
and down searching up and down up and
down up and down right courses here it's
very much sort of a smooth progression
to the top all right yeah this was the
guy who came in last minute copy some of
these codes in influential codes so like
for the intermediate disclosure did were
there a few that people kind of modeled
theirs
exactly I'm sure that in a sector that
basically the the intermediate guys were
able to basically find the
high-performing code you had access to
those code and then you could just boom
go crazy at it versus these guys were
blindly searching alright they had a
score function that they could compare
themselves against but that's it but
they didn't have anybody access to
anybody else's knowledge will do
anything with them okay
and so what we see is that there were
30% was interesting that there were
thirty percent fewer novel techniques in
an intermediate difícil disclosure
simply because you know they just found
the cool stop and they went right after
it or says these guys are exploring much
broadly and these points these lines of
you put them on the same graph never
cross right they're always there the the
clothes and no matter meet your
disclosures regime is typically just
just heads above in terms of
experimentation that's going on and we
have the Harper index of the submissions
and you can sort of see that there's
much more homogeneity concentration here
than here okay and then what we can also
look at is number of high potential
novel approaches versus low potential
novel which is considered and again what
you see is that the that the close guys
do much more exploration on the low end
of the potential approaches and the high
and the open guys are you know pretty
much on the high end okay so so so so
what's happening right is that in the in
the world of enemies of disclosure
people could access to other people's
knowledge right and if you have a
performance metric available you can
then take that and go go crazy and
improve upon that all right but that's
at a cost of less experimentation right
less exploration right and and less
participation and so we have to be able
to balance between those things so you
know again an interview disclosure fewer
participants less effort yet higher
average and maximum performance vast
majority of people will peek and reuse
so of the 32 people that were in our
open disclosure regime right 30 of them
actually did the peeking and reused it's
available why don't you use it
um search behavior more expert
experimentation more exploration in the
final disclosure regime and convergence
and coordination over the best paths and
in terms of disclosure but this has
consequences for us yes incentives right
because this is a fact that some guy at
the end isn't come in and steal my code
and and run off
if you having community water that you
lose what they get a really someone
right and so so we serve so what we're
doing is in our experiment we're trying
to make the difference really sharp to
see in fact what's going on and as I'll
discuss next what we have in and other
systems are compensating mechanisms
right allowing you to actually get
rewards for credit and so forth along
the way as well okay so the thing we
need to think about is an increased
reuse right comes at a cost of lower
incentives and it's highly dependent on
the stock of knowledge being created
right because the stock of knowledge if
the soft knowledge created is not that
great we're going to be in trouble
converging and coordinate behavior you
know relies on the stock of knowledge
available if that's no good then we
won't get the best solutions and the
potential concern that we have here is
that the fitness landscape may in fact
be driving some of this behavior so we
we chose the problem almost blindly
right so we had we were working with the
medical school you know they were highly
skeptical of this approach ever working
for them
right so we said you know what we'll
fund an experiment right ways the cash
prizes and you just find us a cool
problem so if you find a cool problem in
computational biology all right now it
may have been right that basically the
the problem was like this right so one
single peak you find the solution and
you go boom you go after it all right
and everybody can share it but if we're
in a world of rugged landscapes with
lots of peaks and valleys right we may
be in a different world right this
requires broad experimentation this
expires broad search right which the the
the closed regime did
and so you know one of the consequences
of the study is that in fact the choice
of problem you have you know can
actually should then determine the
disclosure policy you're actually
following right you should get the
solution exactly is obviously we need
some more work understanding what our
columns are these could there be corner
solutions or is it just one smooth with
the increasing approach absolutely this
is expose analysis and thinking about it
so so there are comparative advantages
of the different systems right so you
would use an image disclosure when there
is a broad stock of knowledge already
available for reuse right so one of the
things that open source has shown is
that Linux did well because we
understood the UNIX framework right that
was not a mystery right and that allowed
people to then take that knowledge and
then build upon that and elaborate
amazingly well same thing with Wikipedia
but if we were starting a brand-new
operating system you know heard didn't
go anywhere for some reason if you guys
know what that is you know
but-but-but-but a brand new completely
novel conceptualization may have
problems because of these effects the
diversity of participants we argue may
overcome this are local local Optima
concerns that we have so you know we in
our in our study we can control for
skill and so we've actually take away
the diversity that exists but in fact in
the real world there may be different
perspectives and open open source and
open communities may in fact attract
also diverse people and they may not get
locked into these perspectives again
empirical question for us to go after
and of course this compensating
incentives right that there may be other
benefits to participation above and
beyond the final outcome reward that
we're set up and that may drive
participation as well all right in the
file this goes your world useful when
you want broad-based experimentation
right and this is really the startup
economy that we live in right what you
guys are so aware of here in Silicon
Valley all right so so if you think
about
social social media and and and the
explosion of social media right there
were probably about a thousand companies
trying to do what Facebook and Twitter
eventually got done right the the nine
hundred ninety eight of them died and
went away because they were in the low
part and you know two or three did
really well and did it amazingly well so
our our economy set up to actually do
this parallel independent search
depending upon the problem that we have
in front of us and again this is the
insights that you want to start thinking
about here and and even here in terms of
final disclosure in some of the work
we're doing on contest the emphasis that
we have can be on implicit incentives
participation incentives and not just a
nice person incentives and that can also
drive behavior so like when we do these
contests where you know if you have a
thousand people participating and most
of them are losing right there must be
other benefits to participation and we
again see that in them in this set up so
I'm going to end with you know every HBS
professor has to show a two by two or
that's in our contract you know so I'm
just gonna show you a like a two-thirds
by two by two or something like that one
one is a missing element so what you
might think about right are two
dimensions right emphasis on disclosure
of individual advances right versus
emphasis on disclosure of final
innovations okay that's one dimension
and the other is property rights and
exclusion which is disclosure right what
are you putting together so our
industrial innovation system
market-based systems have a have a
process which says we give property
rights in exclusion if you disclose your
final products that's where we're at
alright academic science and public
innovation contests are really geared
towards emphasizing disclosure but only
of final products okay there's a lot of
controversy in science right now that
you know people should list out all
their data right there's a there's a
study out recently that apparently 70%
of biomedical research can't be
replicated which is kind of crazy all
right
and so that's we're in a system where
you know you never get there an
underlying data set you basically get
the the tables and the graphics right so
this is the world we live in and then
what we've seen you know so clearly in
the last decades has been the Human
Genome Project open source and user
innovation
open data open api's biological
repositories all these guys pushing for
disclosure of intermediate advances and
I think what's and so that's how we're
set up right now is our major
institutions for innovation and what's
what's interesting for me is to sort of
say as a b-school prof like what what
are firms doing and if you think about a
company like IBM or Google they're
actually playing in all three dimensions
right so IBM the biggest patter in the
world right also does a lot of
scientific research that they publish
also is the biggest contributor to open
source right Google the contributor open
source scientific research also piloting
right so so in the economy we have P
firms figuring out either through some
master plan or just trial and error
living in these three three regimes and
I think the question for us as academics
and scholars sort of say you know is
this the right way for this particular
problem right or should we be thinking
about alternative ways for us to put
together so the the what's amazing as a
researcher for us right now is that we
can now run these counterfactuals on
real problems with real people and then
get these types of results so I think
I'm almost out of time too so questions
thoughts comments yes whether there's
some way that you can instead of doing
like just all of the problems are
available for you to look at you have
some system which like characterizes
which essentially builds a model of like
suppose suppose you looked at your logs
and then like you basically looked at
the amounts of innovation that results
and then and then like you like whenever
people look at solutions and then like
you can say like for example like people
you make them put something like after
looking at more than two other solutions
then at that point the time like the
benefit of looking at additional ones
kind of decreases it off right and then
are we considered building a system that
kind of a selects
they're people's solutions to disclose -
so instead of giving you like here's
every all the solutions in which case
all you'll do is just look at the top
ones now the top ones instead of that it
basically selects them such that
attempts to maximize your solution
diversity right so suppose you're able
to do that characterization live right
that bit pattern of strategies used in a
business that ok we haven't we have none
of the solution we generate have used
this particular bit pattern us we want
someone to generate it well let's try
and like select some and then just
present it to them and then hopefully
they'll just say click and then like
generate a new solution yeah we haven't
it's hard to do cuz to do to know real
time what the approaches are and we
depart some of your smarts to help us
along the way
I certainly uh you know some of the
things a colleague of mine at math works
at MATLAB they actually run this this
sort of enemies of disclosure contest
all the time so basically they have two
two days of of closed and then five is
of open it's just for for tchotchkes
there's no cash involved and Ned there
has actually said that he's tried to
build systems where you could signal to
other people saying there's a novel bit
of code in here that hasn't been tried
before and get people to sort of raise
their so even though it may score really
poorly there might be an all a bit of
insight that somebody can grab and do
that because you know be a programmer
you need to understand both algorithmic
things but also needs and thinking about
efficiency and how fast you are and that
kind of stuff and some people may not be
good at both and and certainly when
we've done an analysis of the math Morse
code basis we actually see sort of you
can think of the code is in a cassette
right and there's some little gems
inside of it and the question is can
somebody find those gems grab them out
there and then go with it but we haven't
both of a system of that I think that
would be it would be very meaningful
different processing strategies for
problems that have less
Metiria like problem formulation so
proposed policies that the CPC should
consider for reducing AIDS transmission
in this community or that committee I
mean II consider strategies of water
desalinization where you're trying to
generate a problem that is well
specified enough that it could have the
usual metrics but you're trying to
explore the problem characterization yes
wait so you know what you've hit upon it
is in doing this work I think the the
solutions are easy
it's the problems that are now the
constraint how we define the problems
and there's no I think maybe that these
schools have have some some insights but
at least from my perspective there's
really no signs of problem formulation
that exists right now that we can
actually take and replicate we know that
that matters you know I've got a
doctoral student graduating right now he
the Lipchitz who spent a year at NASA
looking at problems not these
competition ones but really hard ones
like you know you know how do you how do
you reduce microbes on the space station
right and how do you form a that problem
right because right now they send you
know liquids up to the space station and
it's $10,000 for a kilogram for up mass
so it matters a lot and how do they
actually do the problem formulation so I
think problem formulation is actually
the the next big thing that those of us
are doing crowd research are gonna be
focusing it on we've done we did this
interesting thing with the Medical
School where we said and have a little
partition of paper out on this where we
said if you think about research it's
completely vertically integrated right
the P I and the lab decides on the
interesting hypothesis and the question
comes up with a proposal sends it to the
NIH right their peers the same community
evaluate and then there's some
possibility of getting funding and
working away what happens if we actually
disaggregate that process what happens
if you actually open up the hypothesis
generation process so we did that with
type one diabetes where we basically
said you know we want you don't need
ability to solve
you need to come up with a really good
question and we have a paper on that one
understand how that how those processes
work as well and then we do the same
thing on evaluation we said not just the
the the close experts but in fact a
whole range of people in the medical
sciences can be evaluating and then we
actually did more work or we said let's
take the these hypotheses and generate
new teams of people that never worked
together before as well so that's the
that's the bleeding edge I don't
understand that but I think I think the
insight about problem formulation is
actually actually critical because you
know we can now with a credit card get
answers really good answers really fast
and then it's a matter of like have you
asked the right questions and and the
finding we have is the question you ask
is the answer you'll get like it's it's
so these guys are so you know so like
there's nothing else but they argue this
is the question this is the Aish metric
right I'm gonna give you the answer if
you look at people who actually create
the innovations right so it's like the
first person to have passed a threshold
like some professional scorer asked at
some time T right have you looked at
like like I assume you log like which
other solutions people would have looked
at right like have you looked at like
approximately how many other solutions
you need to look at before you're able
to like on average before you look like
sheep with new innovation is doing some
magic number or so there's another paper
I'm working on right now where we look
at is your ability to invent related to
your ability to copy okay so you mention
capability and copying capabilities so
and what we're finding is that you
become a better inventor as you as you
copy more so the quality of your
inventions are better once you've
learned and there's and this this effect
runs both ways so as you invent more
you're better at copying as well you
find better stuff to copy as well again
from an economist reminded me this is a
hard study for us to do because we've
got all this in dodge and AD going on
and we have a bunch of controls and
fixed effects and so for the deal with
that but we feel pretty comfortable
about this finding that in fact there's
a virtuous circle between in
and copying coming together right and
that that's that's the society right I'd
be the people you know there's no sort
of lone geniuses you're in you're
embedded in a world of the other ideas
and from that you formulate something
coming out of it
and that we use the math works data for
judge again at briefly about a you're
tracking of like the rate of innovation
so we look at like what's the marginal
impact of each co2 right and even
looking at that over time right or
they're bigger leaps initially then
there are later on or someone that can
you speak briefly what kind of what
you've seen there yeah that's a really a
function of the problem itself so what
we find is an asymptote right basically
is you know initially there's a lots of
big things and then it's harder and
harder to eke out the performance gains
and but I think that's that's more us
being unaware of the solution space that
exists right be sort of see it
instantiated as people work away and and
this is this is the debate that we have
like it's two weeks enough or should we
have five weeks because what we find is
that two weeks maybe actually enough to
get you wafer they're headed there's no
need to spend another three weeks
working on a problem as well so I'm
wondering under the close regime if you
look at the distribution of strategies
that people use yes you argue that
there's some correlation between the
strategy and success yes and I'm
wondering whether there's an effect of
how many people Center in on that
strategy do people actually know which
strategy independently is going to be
successful or not yes and I can
translate this to another domain you
know these courses here like last year a
surprising number of projects dealt with
finding bathrooms on the Stanford campus
does that signal that this is a really
important easy that if you built this
everyone would start using it or you
know is they're actually less similar
than you might think that it's maybe an
obvious thing to design for and yes
meaningful solution yeah but not a
little off yeah yeah so I haven't you
know looked at sort of the sort of
so at least the data that we show is
that there is more diversity in the
strategies being used by people working
in blindly all right
and the the and so that in itself is a
good outcome for innovation because we
want diverse experiments to take place
so so the answer would be we see more
you don't see correlation in search
strategies when once you're applying it
which sort of makes sense right you sort
of have your own edition credit
knowledge and given the types of people
be attracted they weren't all from
Stanford they're from around the world
different backgrounds different training
and they and and and and and that's
probably drove people pause on that many
different yeah absolutely yeah so could
you imagine using a combination of both
final disclosure and intermediate
because in the final disclosure you want
to get all of these like all this
knowledge you build it all up but at
some point would imagine convergence is
helpful yes I think I think I think I
think I think if we can somehow figure
out the right way to and semi's people
to do both or the your try different
crowds I think I think that depends on
whose perspective are you taking right
from a social planners perspective this
is what you might do you might say I'm
gonna lots of diversity initially then I
want convergence right then I want more
diversity and this is like design
thinking right like you want diversity
then you want convergence and you want
to diversity and you want convergence
yes well they're just exploring
exploring but once they come out with
something that they want others yeah and
the business can be sustained the broad
exploration in our organization
typically most of organizations will any
problems might have one team maybe two
barrel teams but that's it yeah
and you say that if this one actually
has the best have approved of a learning
more than the other group that for
example could be the best one of that
good that wins the task but the others
didn't know anything because was always
pros yes many I think the learning
question is a really important question
and I don't have good answers for that
exam mean I think you know it's hard for
us to be able to judge what they might
have learned you know they looked at
somebody else's code at the end of the
contest all the code was ill with
everybody else to use are the skills and
so forth so that's a hard really hard
question I try to find easy easy
questions with easy answers
you